[Music]
[Laughter]
take it that's the ticket
take it sit down tickle oh you feet the
spicy Italians come on mummy Jesus
Christ this nutmeg with Nicky red sauce
good danhype it looks good but to see
the potato
oh it's that type of afternoon you bad
[__] give me that lighter gee
money oh yeah
biggie smalls Julia mafia what
[Music]
who you play with - with the Jews 118
hanging down [__] four of you
I love it when you call me big papa what
are you [__] kidding me or what it's
Sunday and we're taking this
[__] the new levels on Sunday
right here but you [__] [__] in my
palm that's all I want I'm saying that's
what Jesus wanted for farm Sunday put
that monkey in my [__] palm you bad
[__] it's a beautiful day to be
alive and they feel stupendous [__] a
dollar and a dream your friends I get my
friends and we'll give each other
chlamydia yet I'm saying keep banging
[__] salud
[Music]
this is all the way mate I'll [__] the
[__] that's it right there
go away if you want if you ain't [__]
down then you ain't down I understand
well here's the church it's all about
respect
what here you go this is real deal right
here
oh yeah is that Moretz we don't split
nothing here Sunday little something
sunset herbal a little King Louie the
Dewey this is just straight-up debt son
Center but where you going with that
link [__]
[Music]
got a little TKO to knock off this
[__] ready for the likes of this
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with here on Sunday
sandwiches reflux bong hits it's all
over it's all over this movie that
should be having my baby baby bird oh
here we go you bad [__] [__] you
want to throw heat today there's nothing
on TV you got some finals choose 60
minutes the hook is gonna [__] some [__]
but besides that it's your uncle [__]
Joey coming at you direct podcasting
music whatever today it's all out it's a
[__] Thanksgiving smorgasbord here on
the [__] church will you [__]
you thinking peeling with what oh [__]
rock this and cocoa let's go it's the
man himself
if you don't know no trivia what's the
trivia from this long Michael Rapaport
what's this run from what be what's the
soundtrack come on baby
that's who shoots at my boy at first
yeah that's what they're playing without
the lyrics who the [__] you think you're
talking to
not yet
[__] the football myself disrespect
myself put the drugs on the show now
good see it came to New York I wanna be
[__] what boy are you [__]
kidding me are you [__] kidding me
are you the CIA analyst this little fat
[__] dude they had to kill him
listen we was dropping was dropping
[__] always on the Lord's Day
Palm Sunday what [__] what do you think
Lee Martin Lee Harvey Weinstein ain't
got a [__] palm on his [__] monkey
right now what oh [__]
he's doing the know he's doing a wine
he's doing the what pass on it I hope
he's a RINO god what the [__] for the
Yankees but a [__] Yankees for the
Yankees they're gonna go [__] maybe
later that type of party today
[__] the family gets together
with the muffler on the check respect
[__] oh [__] it's time for a
little meal you gotta give the little
meal some love from time to time I'm
good my brother you your family okay you
working tomorrow
I love it he's very nice to get together
with you [__] on the Lord's Day
we're just trying to have a good time
when I proven none this is what the
[__] is the future hey we get
together we go for bondage you hear
people argue and this is what it's all
about you don't like it go somewhere
else
go watch bad TV some might say this is
good TV and here in arguments you're
hearing gossip people smoke and dope
they eat the sandwiches Biggie's getting
his dick sucked on the album hold on one
second music sure Trump I never be
President he never thought it [__] big
man from Queens from Jamaica estates the
Donald is to come out is code seven
o'clock
[Music]
we go early early Aerosmith couple more
bonnets we'll talk some more [__] and
then you figure it out and I'm saying
it's early are you ready for bang
[Music]
a [__] period piece can you believe
this tell you who to go see my friend
will set you free
tell them what you need them maybe I can
go - no one knows away but maybe me
nobody goes there nobody knows that what
[Music]
are you [__] nuts
oh [__] that's the move today the
handles on quietly I'm looking like
[__] Willy Cologne in 73 and that's
all that matters you know I'm saying
don't forget Columbus no Saturday night
ice house 9:30 working out with uncle
Joey Tuesday night I need all you
[__] time to do at The Comedy Store
it says 16 comments on the schedule just
get the [__] tickets 9:30 15 minutes
for Netflix I need you [__]
there about the stabber [__]
take it over la Boulevard reefer in the
back later don't worry about nothing
I'll see you down there Tuesday night if
not I'll see you saturday at the Ice
House at 9:30 working I would love Joey
if I left it says yes we gotta go on to
work it out spree you're gonna get
videos you're gonna get everything
everything that's how we doing it right
now yeah you little producer here Lee
rocking it
let's do a little bonding and that's it
nobody one more dog you're good to go
you can't walk on one and I'm saying
yeah you need two legs to one minute you
don't want a little meal a little milk
alright do you think yeah do a little
more I got some [__] I got from the
business [__] that [__] kill the
chick from Star Wars kill Princess Leia
that [__] had everything his
sister God perhaps I'm saying God have
[__] anyway I forgot the words I'm
[__] starving for me we're about to
do a [__] podcast I'm an old man I
got to mention I'm high together and I'm
saying dementia meet stone this at the
same time here we go
listen too early heaven with Joe Perry
right here
[Music]
what you gonna do youtube.com slash c /
joey dear santa ana casino sold out what
do you got you got columbus ohio 420
going in there [__] throwing Heat
I'm helicopter love that [__]
with Kate Quigley but Tuesday night LA
[__] I'll see you at the store
about 9:15 I go up at 9:30 we're gonna
[__] that room up you understand me
out of respect for the church what's
happened now cuz remember without you
[__] I got Oh guys I got
nothing without you guys you guys made
this all possible and your title up my
[__] game cuz you savages
metal [__] sharpens metal and then
look at the 37 you know I'm saying
anyway
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz is the
place to be
oh [__] now we're walking the dog
[Music]
there's the first Aerosmith down no
Buscemi sent your sandwiches here we go
what here we go [__] this
[__] this proposal to say this
pedophile this periscope is brought to
you by [__] uncle paulie's down there
Beverly [__] Hills so go visit
them they hooked us up today with some
sandwiches real [__] sandwiches not
this [__] based all around here and they
make you drive two hours I know I try
but I wanna have in the 405 and your
sandwich sucks I'm gonna be pissed so I
just mind my business I make my own
anyway I love you [__]
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
what are you I'm gonna [__] tell you
get them same Knicks over here look at
Nick getting ready for baseball
[Music]
yo youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz 10
minutes let's get this party started
Michael Rapaport Nick the Toro
sandwiches